Transcriber: Berivan Pektaş
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Alpçetin
Merhaba.
Bugün size niyet, gayret
ve cesareti anlatacağım.
eşitCV CEO’su olarak karşınızdayım.
Bizim için imkansız gibi
görünen bazı şeylerin
inanç ve çaba ile imkanlı hale
gelebileceğini anlatmak istiyorum.
Peki ben bu noktaya nasıl geldim?
Hayatımın birçok noktasında,
her konuda mücadele ettim.
Mücadelelerin arasında
topluluk önünde konuşmak var.
Bugün de biraz heyecanlıyım
ve heyecanımı yenmek için
mücadele edeceğim.
Beş yaşıma kadar
sıradan bir çocukluk dönemi geçirdim
fakat beşinci yaşım
hayatımın dönüm noktası oldu.
Geçirdiğim havale sonucu sağ bacağımda
kas gerginliği meydana geldi
ve serebral palsi tanısı konuldu.
Hastalığın ilk döneminde
hayati riskim vardı.
Risk geçtikten sonra durumumu kabul ettim
ve fizik tedavi egzersizlerine başladım.
5 yaşlarında hastalığa yakalandım.
İlk yıllarda kekemeliğim vardı
ve konuşamaz oldum.
Bu yüzden her gün kitap okuyarak
ve çeşitli çalışmalar yaparak
kekemeliğimi yendim.
7 yaşında fizik tedavi egzersizlerini
yapmaya başladım.
Felç kalsam da
sonradan geçirdiğim ameliyatlar
ve uyguladığım fizik tedavi egzersizleri
beni durumundan
daha iyi bir duruma getirdi
ve zamanla bende yarattığı
sıkıntıları atlatmaya başladım.
Girişimciliğe ilk adımımı 10 yaşında
bir arkadaşımla birlikte
oyuncak satarak adım attım
ve yaptığım sayısız girişimlerde
başarısızlık yaşasam da
girişimcilik alanında
sürekli aksiyonlar almaya devam ettim.
Okul, fizik tedavi ve girişimcilik ile
hayata tutunma çabam vardı
ve sürekli aksiyon alıyordum.
Bu girişimcilik işlerinden dolayı
hayatımdaki fırsatların kovalayıp
hepsini keşfetmeye çalışıyordum.
16-17 yaşlarındaydım,
iş kurmak istiyordum.
Bir arkadaşım ile bankadan
kredi çekebileceğimizi düşündük
ve bir bankaya gittik.
Kredi çekmek istediğimizi söyledik.
Banka memuru bize
ne iş yapıyorsunuz dediğinde
biz birbirimize bakıp
çalışmadığımızı söylemiştik
ve bu noktada nakit arayışımız da
olumsuz sonuçlanmış oldu.
2017 yılında Marmara Üniversitesi
BESYO bölümünü kazansam da
doktorların ameliyat kararından dolayı
gidemedim ve okulu bir yıl erteledim.
Daha sonra hem fizik tedaviye giderek
hem de üniversite sınavlarına çalışarak
tekrar sınavlara girdim
ve Haliç Üniversitesi
Halkla İlişkiler ve Tanıtım bölümünü
tam burslu olarak kazandım.
Kendimi bulmak için
yeniden mücadele verdim.
Başardığım şeyden vazgeçerek
tekrar bir şey başardım
ve daha da önemlisi
sosyal bir insan olarak
sosyal bir bölüm kazandım.
Hayatta tekrar
bir şey başarabileceğimi gördüm.
Üniversitede ise
güzel arkadaşlıklar edindim
ve mutlu oldum.
Üniversiteye girdikten sonra
dijital girişimcilikle tanıştım
ve bu alanda
kendimi geliştirmeye başladım.
Her geçen gün farklı şeyler öğrenmeye
devam ettim ve hala da devam ediyorum.
Öğrenmenin ve üretmenin
mücadelesini veriyorum.
Öte yandan öğrendiklerimle
insanlara fayda sağlayacak şeyler
üretmeye çalışıyorum.
Ürettiğim bu şey ise engelli istihdamını
kolaylaştıracak bir web platform.
Bu web platformunu engelli insanlar için
ürettim ve çok uğraşıyorum.
Engelli bireylerin durumunu anladığım
ve iyi bildiğim için
onlara güzel bir şey sunmak istiyorum.
Bugün bakıldığında maalesef
her 10 engelliden sekizi
hayata küsmüş durumda.
Ben ürettiklerimle ve deneyimlerimle
18 engelli bireyi de hayata döndürüp
bir şeyler başarılabileceğini
göstermek istiyorum.
Üniversitede okurken işe ihtiyacım vardı
ve iş bulabilmek için tüm alternatifleri
kullanmama rağmen iş bulamadım
ve sonrasında baktığımda
diğer engelli insanların da
benim gibi iş bulmakta güçlük çektiğini
ve hatta o ara engelli olan insanların da
iş ararken bana göre
daha çok zorlandığını fark ettim.
Tüm bunlar başımdan geçtikten sonra
kendime bir söz verdim.
İş bulması sürecinde karşılaştığım
ve gördüğüm sorunlar konusunda
bir çözüm üretecektim
ve bu çözüm için kolları sıvadım.
Öncelikle bu alanda birçok eğitimlere
ve seminerlere katılarak
kendimi geliştirmeye başladım.
Gerekli tüm bilgilere sahip olduktan sonra
tasarlayacağım web platformu için
çalışmaya başladım.
Platformu geliştirirken
kurumların insan kaynakları departmanına
ulaşmam gerekiyordu.
Ulaşmakta güçlük çekiyordum
ve ısrar ettim.
Bir kurumu iki hafta boyunca
her gün aradım ve mail attım.
En sonunda onlar beni aramıştı
ve “Senin derdin ne?” demişlerdi.
Bu platformda tasarladığım şey ise
engellilerin iş hayatına katılmadan önce
pozisyonlara göre eğitimler alıp
kendilerini geliştirerek
iş ilanlarına başvurmalarını,
işe yerleştirilmelerini
ve aynı zamanda işverenlere de engelli
bireyler ile ilgili eğitim vermeyi,
kişilerin engel durumlarına göre
hangi departmana
yerleştirileceğini aktaran
eğitimler ve engel grupları hakkında
bilgiler veren eğitimler vermeyi
amaçlayan bir web platformu.
Bu platformu tasarladıktan sonra,
birçok kuluçka merkezinde
yarışmalara katılıp dereceler elde ettim.
Sonrasında projeyi hayata geçirmek için
adımlar atmaya başladım.
Fakat tabii üye olduğum sürece
hiçbir bilgimim olmadığı bir alandı
ve yazılım için tanıdığım
az sayıda insan vardı.
Yazılım süreci için
birçok uzmana gitsem de
kimi yanlış yönlendirdi,
kimi ise dolandırmaya çalıştı.
Sonrasında bu yolda verdiğim
tüm mücadeleyi
birkaç YouTube videosu ile
insanlara anlatmaya çalıştım
ve bu mecrada birçok arkadaş edindim
ve platform için çözüm yolu ararken
bir araba galerisi ile tanıştım.
Onlarla projem için görüştük
ve işbirliği yapmamız konusunda anlaştık
ve öğrenciliğim devam ederken
birçok projede yer aldım.
Bunlardan ilki Dreamstalk.
Burada marka yaratma
ve maksimize eğitimleri olarak
ekip arkadaşlarımla beraber
istediğim spor giyim markası yarattık.
Markada belirlediğimiz vizyon ise
kazandığımız gelirin bir kısmı ile
sosyal ve ekonomik açıdan
geride kalmış ülkelerde
ekstrem spor organizasyonları düzenleyerek
bu ülkelerde insanları
spor ile buluşturmak.
Sonrasında
okulumdaki bir kulübün düzenlediği
köy okulu destek projesine katılarak
Anadolu’daki bir köy okulunun
ihtiyaçlarını gidermek adına destek oldum.
Sonrasında bir dernek için
ekip arkadaşlarımızla birlikte
görme engelli çocukların eğitim
materyallerinin değişmesi için düzenlenen
maddi destek projesinde yer aldım.
18 buçuk saat sürdürülebilirlik projesiyle
gençlere yönelik
hem sürdürülebilirlik, kalkınma amaçları
hem de proje üretebilme ve uygulayabilmek
konularında farkındalık oluşturma,
yaşadığı bölgedeki sorunları tespit etme,
bu sorunları projelendirerek
hayata geçirme
ve kişisel ağlarını genişletme gibi
yetkinliklerin kazandırılması ile
sonrasında arkadaşlarımla birlikte
Gri Bölge adında bir inisiyatif kurduk.
Gri Bölge ile giderek artan
toplumsal kutuplaşmayla derdi olan,
kendisine benzemeyenleri tanımak,
anlamak isteyen farklı kimlik ve görüşten
yirmi sekiz genç olarak
bağımsız bir gençlik inisiyatifi kurduk.
Good4Trust ile üretim ekonomisini,
sosyal girişimciliği,
kapsayıcılık ve erişilebilirliği dahil
yakından tanırken
bolca fikir üretip birbirimizi besledik.
Good4Trust’ın bu program ile
çok farklı hikayeleri, amaçları
ve dönüşüm arzuları olan
akranlarınla bir araya gelebilmek,
hepimizin hikayesinde ortak bir nokta olan
daha iyi bir dünya yaratmak konusunda
düşünmek ve öğrenmek çok güzeldi.
Bu girişimcilik mücadelesinin
arka planında
fiziksel olarak
size yakın şartlara ulaşmak için
her gün 4 saat egzersiz yapıyorum.
7 yaşından bu yana yaptığım
egzersizleri hesapladığımda
hayatımdaki 22 bin saate denk geliyor.
Konuşmamın başında belirttiğim
niyet, gayret ve cesaretin
gayret kısmını
bu çabam ve inancım oluşturuyor.
Son olarak dinlediğiniz için
hepinize teşekkür ederim.